i i would make a case so the the variety
of artists that you worked with and
brought the best out of it does seem
that you're out of this world
so
do you think you would know
like
if you're the same kind of species maybe
you're just a meat vehicle and you're
channeling ideas from somewhere else i
feel like i'm channeling ideas from
somewhere else 100
but i think have you asked questions
about where from i believe we all i
believe we all are though you know i
believe
we are um
we're vehicles
for information
that when it's ready to come through it
comes through and the people who have
good antennas pick up the signal
but um if
i'm sure you've had an experience in
your life where you've had an idea for
something and you've not acted on it and
eventually someone else does it and it's
not because they're doing it because you
had the idea and they stole your ideas
because
the time has come for that idea
and if you don't do it someone else is
going to it's being broadcast by
whatever the source is whatever the
source is
uh
yeah i don't do
i tend to see humans as not quite
special in that way yeah it's it's
different kinds of antennas walking
around listening to ideas and ideas that
are
i like the the notion of uh richard
dawkins of memes
or it's kind of the ideas of the
organisms and they're just using our
brains to multiply to
to select to compete
to evolve
and humans we really want to hold on to
the specialness of our body of our mind
but it's it's really the ideas so if
rick rubin was born
two centuries ago
you wouldn't be a music producer you'd
be
or i mean maybe
but
you have an antenna
and if no signals coming in
uh or you'd be hearing potentially a
different signal
is there um
i think we all have our own antenna for
whatever it is that we you know maybe
not everyone has
tuned into their antenna to see what it
is that
their strength in bringing through is
i'm lucky in that it found me because i
didn't know that it was a i didn't even
know this was a job
you